[Musique]
vous êtes vous êtes les bienvenus dans
auditions publiques tous les lundis
soirs sur LCP Public Sénat un invité ou
une invité une invitée en l'occurrence
puisque nous avons plaisir de recevoir
ce soir Valérie rabot merci à vous
d'être là Valérie Rimbault première
vice-présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
ancienne rapporteur du budget vos
interventions sont toujours factuelles
vous n'êtes pas très fan des effets de
manche le buzz très peu pour vous vous
êtes dans le genre sérieux est-ce que le
PS qui va tenir bientôt son congrès va
prendre au sérieux vos positions on va
en parler tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée
nationale 6e recours au 49-3 vendredi
soir vous avez tempêté contre cette
pratique répétée du gouvernement mais
pouvait-il faire autrement pour avoir un
budget n'attipal chercher le compromis
repris certaines de vos propositions sur
la réforme des retraites y a-t-il un
accord possible la faire cadenas doit-il
démissionner et surtout quelles règles
adopter face à ce type de cas qui
bouscule désormais les parties la
conséquence les conséquences plus
généralement d'un gouvernement sans
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
vous y reviendrez avec Brigitte Boucher
est intraduit l'avenir du PS après les
1,75 % d'Ann Hidalgo à la présidentielle
vous y reviendrez avec Sophie dravinel
les questions d'actu avec Jean-Baptiste
sémardian mais d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur votre tribune celle que vous
avez signé avec Carole delgat hier dans
le Journal du Dimanche la gauche dont
nous faisons partie ne représente plus
une voix d'avenir pour les Français
n'est pas le moral alors on a la grande
déprime pour vous non non c'est pas la
grande déprime mais il faut toujours
être lucide sur le point de départ il
faut faire un constat très clair nous
gagnons des élections au niveau local
nous présidons huit régions sur 15
Carole delgat avec qui j'ai cosiné cette
tribune et la présidente de région de
France elle a été la mieux élue de tous
les présidents et présidente religion
nous présidons un tiers quand je dis
nous c'est le parti socialiste des
départements en France des grandes
villes et pour autant nous ne
transformons pas laissé au niveau
national donc ça pose question et au
niveau national et bien il y a toujours
deux questions qui se posent
l'incarnation et le cap qu'on veut
donner à un pays l'incarité et le cas
présenter votre corps et le cap c'est
d'abord le cas pour d'abord
l'incarnation je pense que c'est d'abord
alors en général on marche sur deux
jambes donc c'est souvent ça marche l'un
avec l'autre mais le cap n'est pas
l'addition de politique locale n'est pas
l'addition de mesures qui pourraient
exister c'est vraiment de dire quelle
est la force intérieure qu'on donne à
une société ou qu'on a envie de faire
rayonner ou qu'on a envie de propulser
et donc ces interrogations là mais elle
se pose en premier lieu à nous qui
sommes élus et depuis des années mais
couvrait
ça fait 5 ans qu'elle se pose peut-être
un peu plus et donc il y a un congrès du
Parti socialiste nous avons souhaité
dire des choses avec Carole Delga vous
voulez compter vous faites quand même un
constat assez terrible dans cette
tribune vous dites que la gauche choisit
l'émotion plus que la raison c'est à
dire
que
moi je fais partie de ceux qui aiment
les sciences les mathématiques
d'ailleurs vous quand on relie une
ancienne matheuse
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que quand on relie même les les textes
de la Révolution française si les
savants n'avaient pas pris leur les
scientifiques n'avaient pas pris leur
part à cette révolution elle n'aurait
jamais été ce qu'elle a été et donc tout
au long de des républiques qui se sont
succédés dans notre pays on voit que les
sciences le progrès ont été un moteur
très important même François Mitterrand
dont tout le monde connaît le goût pour
la littérature a écrit dans sa lettre
aux Français en 1988 un passage sur les
sciences qui est fantastique qui est de
dire dans le fond quand on veut exister
sur la scène internationale certains
voudraient des utilisent des guerres ce
qui est quand même terrible pour
l'humanité et d'autres passent par les
sciences par Le Progrès ça c'est écrit
dans la lettre de François Mitterrand
1988 dont tout le monde sait qu'il était
littéraire qu'il aimait beaucoup lire
sans doute on sait moins que il avait
dans le fond une forme d'admiration donc
vous choisissez pour enfin comme parrain
intellectuel François Mitterrand pour
mais encore une fois vous vous dites la
gauche choisi l'émotion plus que la
raison donnez-moi un exemple qui fait
que l'émotion prime sur la raison à
gauche ces dernières semaines ou ces
derniers mois mais quand on a vu la
quand on dit qu'on la émotion prime par
rapport à la raison c'est dans le fond
les choix qu'on a à faire c'est est-ce
qu'on choisit plus la voix populiste ou
est-ce qu'on a choisi plus la voix de la
raison et c'est toujours une voix plus
difficile la voix de la raison ne pas se
laisser entraîner dans des émotions qui
peuvent gagner une société et se dire
maintenant le fond il faut porter ce cap
et ça c'est plus difficile c'est plus
exigeant plus difficile et c'est plus
exigeant et c'est des gens que la
stratégie dont vous parlez aussi celle
du clash permanent exactement la refusez
moi je fais pas partie de ceux qui
revendiquent le clash permanent ben non
je l'ai d'abord
oui mais parce que je pense que d'abord
je sais pas faire donc c'est peut-être
un premier point
effectivement qui explique que je ne le
fais pas et je pense qu'en plus c'est
pas la politique doit de prendre un peu
de
hauteur ou de dignité par rapport aux
enjeux difficiles de la société en tout
cas c'est ma conception des choses je
sais qu'elle est pas toujours partagée
mais je pense que c'est vraiment une
exigence qu'on doit se fixer à soi-même
pour pouvoir véritablement être en
capacité de changer la société parce que
c'est bien ça aussi qui nous est demandé
faut des choix clairs encore un mot
quand même parce qu'on tourne parfois un
peu autour du pot la stratégie c'est
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui avait théorisé la
nécessité du bruit de la flore en
politique pour faire avancer ses
convictions et ses idées vous n'êtes pas
de cette famille là mais je reconnais à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'avoir eu une
stratégie quand d'autres n'en n'ont pas
et sa stratégie il l'a mené aussi en
proposant la formation de la nuque il a
eu une stratégie jusqu'au bout et donc
je lui reconnais d'avoir eu cette
stratégie là que d'autres peut-être
n'ont pas eu mais la stratégie du clash
permanent qu'on voit parfois à l'heure à
l'Assemblée c'est pas votre truc non et
vous dites c'est pas c'est pas avec ça
qu'on reconstruit le parti soci
Brigitte boucher tamtrane se sont
installés en face de vous on commence
avec vous Tam avec une affaire qui est
maintenant portée dans la justice oui
l'affaire McKinsey la suite le parquet
national financier en quête donc
actuellement sur l'intervention de
mckinzed dans les campagnes
présidentielles de 2017 et 2022 plus
précisément sur ce qu'on appelle les
interventions pro-bonaux des
interventions dont tu aurais profité le
candidat donc ça veut dire pour ceux qui
ne savent pas Emmanuel Macron gratuite
sans avoir à les payer est-ce que vous
saluez l'ouverture de ces enquêtes alors
comme je n'en sais absolument rien
j'imagine que si les enquêtes sont
ouvertes c'est qu'il y a des éléments et
je n'ai jamais commenté de décision de
justice dont je ne le ferai pas ce soir
non plus maintenant si vous me parlez de
l'État et de pourquoi l'État a besoin
d'avoir autant recours à des consultants
j'avais il y a deux un an et demi
j'avais fait un échange croisé avec
Amélie de Montchal où je reproche à ce
gouvernement vous voyez par exemple de
vouloir supprimer d'avoir voulu
supprimer les corps techniques de l'État
ça veut dire que les corps techniques ce
sont les techniciens les ingénieurs vous
dites l'État n'a plus les moyens du coup
d'intervenir au niveau des vouloir
supprimer
le président de la République et le
gouvernement vous êtes un jeune
ingénieur diplômé vous rentrez dans la
fonction publique donc comme vous êtes
payé moins en général que dans le privé
si vous le faites c'est parce que vous
croyez vraiment au service public et en
plus on vous dit vous aurez peut-être un
chef qui aura été qui aura fait une
histoire de l'art et qui vous apportera
pas des compétences techniques dont vous
avez besoin à 25 ans parce qu'à 25 ans
on a besoin d'avoir un chef qui puisse
vous guider et je respecte tout à fait
les formations d'histoire de l'art ne me
faites pas dire ce que j'ai pas dit je
dis juste quand on est ingénieur on a
besoin de pouvoir exercer ses
compétences au sein de l'État ça le
gouvernement a voulu le supprimer
donc il a fallu qu'on monte au créneau
on a été plusieurs à le faire pour que
l'État garde ses corps techniques sinon
à force de le dépecer et de le priver de
ses compétences
il y a un certain nombre de compétences
qui n'existent plus tout le recours à
des cabinets de conseils que vous
justifiez mais je ne le justifie pas je
le constate moi ce que si vous me posez
la question je préfère que l'État est
des compétences je peux vous citer tout
un tas de domaines où il y en a plus et
je préférais que l'État soit en capacité
d'avoir en interne ses compétences de
pouvoir prendre des licences vous savez
quand il y a des industriels qui me
disent aujourd'hui on a plus de capacité
d'échanger avec l'État parce que bah ils
ont il y a personne en face avec qui on
discute personne ne peut dans le fond
fixer des Caps stratégiques et je vais
donner un autre exemple Obama quand il
était président des États-Unis toutes
les deux semaines il recevait son
chiffre sciences officer donc la
personne qui et qui lui disait ben voilà
les grands enjeux scientifiques de
l'époque voilà comment on peut orienter
les politiques de recherche toutes les
deux semaines donc ça doit être porté au
ballon au niveau de l'État et l'État
justement des compétences Bruno Le Maire
reconnaît lui des abus avec les cabinets
de conseils des recours excessifs au
cabinet de conseils il dit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est corriger est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui est-ce que
vous dites pardonné non je pense que
alors je pense que ce n'est pas corrigé
je pense qu'il en a pris conscience et
d'ailleurs j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'en
discuter avec Bruno Le Maire notamment
sur la capacité des corps techniques
donc c'était sur ce sujet là
maintenant il faut que si l'État veut
vraiment être crédible et bien il faut
qu'il publie chaque année de manière
extrêmement exhaustive et précise
transparente transparente la liste des
consultants qui ont été rémunérés par
l'État le montant est pour quelle
mission et d'avoir un document de
synthèse parce qu'ils vont vous dire que
ça existe déjà qu'on peut le trouver oui
mais enfin s'il y a 15000 pages personne
va aller chercher dans les 15000 alors
justement il y a des sénateurs qui
veulent par amendement au projet de loi
de finances de 2023 encadrer les
cabinets de conseils est-ce que c'est
une bonne idée et si cet amendement
arrive à l'Assemblée vous êtes prêtes à
voter oui moi je suis prête je trouve
que effectivement ça fait partie d'un
c'est totalement pas transparent
aujourd'hui donc je veux que on puisse
avoir une liste précise qu'on définisse
peut-être un plafond maximal de
prestations qui peut pas être dépassé
par consultant et puis savoir exactement
ce qu'ils font
alors on passe aux 49-3 oui vendredi
soir le gouvernement a de nouveau
utilisé le 49-3 donc c'était pour la
nouvelle lecture du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
c'était pas une surprise imagine
nouvelle lecture on l'avait déjà eu en
première lecture c'est normal que ça
évite maintenant de logique première
lecture deuxième lecture non mais on
peut se poser la question de
l'utilisation du 49-3 alors comme j'aime
bien faire des petites recherches et moi
j'ai pris la première lecture de la loi
de finances c'était pas la loi de la
sécurité sociale mais la première
lecture la loi de finance ça a été le
49-3 était activé 6 fois depuis 1958 sur
une première lecture de loi de finance
et bien les 6 fois précédentes on est
allé jusqu'au bout du texte là on n'a
pas il y a plein de missions qu'on a pas
du tout étudié ni les crédits de la
gendarmerie
doit être voté dans un délai de 70 jours
vous savez ça mieux point mais vous
savez que on aurait pas eu le temps de
tout examiner la majorité relative et
c'est parfaitement l'Assemblée nationale
et son règlement vous savez qu'il y a un
article 95 qui permet au gouvernement de
mettre les gros articles au début c'est
à dire ceux qui pèsent beaucoup comme
par exemple la suppression de la CVAE
mais il ne l'a pas fait donc quoi
je n'en sais rien je n'en sais rien en
tout cas moi je trouve que c'est
vraiment une opportunité manquée et que
là-dessus il aurait pu donner des gages
deuxièmement les non mais pourquoi faire
dans le fond mais parce que là on est
face à une une rupture démocratique
quand vous avez 21 des 26 articles qui
n'ont pas été examinés sur les recettes
et que vous avez plus de 40 missions
enfin en tout cas 35 missions sur les
crédits qui n'ont pas été examinés ça
veut dire quoi il y a quand même de
débat pour la première lecture par
exemple du budget
quand vous regardez les tous les
amendements parce que c'était après
l'article 1 qui avait lieu je pense que
il aurait été beaucoup plus intéressant
de partir sur les 8 milliards de la CVAE
de le mettre au début et ça le
gouvernement avait la possibilité de
49-3 c'est constitutionnel vous vous
remettez pas 59 3 c'est constitutionnel
mais j'observe juste que pour la
première fois sous la Cinquième
République par rapport aux 49,3 qui ont
été déclenchés auparavant les 6
auparavant qui ont été déclenchés sur
une première lecture de loi de finances
et bien une brèche a été ouverte donc
peut-être une davantage la démocratie
elle débat à l'Assemblée
c'est ce que vous avez dit vendredi vous
avez dit le gouvernement dépossédé
l'assemblée de son de son pouvoir vous
votre pouvoir finalement c'est de vous
opposer en déposant une motion de
censure et en la votant pourquoi vous le
faites pas mais c'est pas d'abord on
vote une mention de censure quand on
arrive à réunir une majorité pour
renverser un gouvernement c'est quand
même ça le principe d'une motion de
censure sinon si jamais qui va forcément
le voter oui vous connaissez un peu les
équilibres donc on s'est quand même
faire deux trois additions et une un
équilibre arithmétique ce qui compte
c'est aujourd'hui c'est si le
gouvernement voulait nous dit on discute
avec les oppositions ce qu'il faut parce
que sur 1500 milliards d'euros de
dépenses publiques il pouvait très bien
combien vous pensez-vous qu'il en a
octroyé aux oppositions via les
amendements retenus moins de
0,05%. donc ça c'est pas un budget où
l'opposition a eu sa marque de fabrique
à quel endroit que ce soit vous avez
quand même le gouvernement dit juste sur
cette question au gouvernement dit ça
sert à une discuter de toute façon
l'opposition de votre APPLE budget
gagnant du temps ça fait gagner du temps
en français puisque pardon au
Gouvernement au Parlement et puis les
Français
mais le dit même au MoDem qui est son
partenaire lorsqu'il refuse un
amendement qui a été voté par 229 voies
donc là maintenant Jean-Paul Mattei sur
les super dividendes Jean-Paul mettei
président du groupe modem à l'Assemblée
nationale
et franchement que vous avez que le
gouvernement les retiré ça salit
beaucoup de choses ça dit quoi ça dit
que on est sur une forme de brèche une
brèche démocratique je trouve dangereuse
dans le peu d'amendements qui ont été
retenus il y a quand même un de vos
amendements votre abonnement sur la TVA
réduite pour les masques par exemple
vous avez quand même obtenu gain de
cause sur un certain nombre de choses
non mais c'est un amendement un peu vous
dites quoi c'est quand vous regardez la
masse budget c'est très important mais
quand vous regardez la masse budgétaire
que ça représente on est quand même très
loin de ce qu'il aurait par exemple je
vais prendre un autre amendement porté
par ma collègue
qui était de dire aujourd'hui vous êtes
dans un EHPAD vous pouvez bénéficier
d'un crédit d'impôt ce qui suit une
réduction d'impôts ce qui suppose que
vous payez de l'impôt sur le revenu mais
si vous ne payez pas d'impôt sur le
revenu vous n'avez pas de soutien donc
là c'était un amendement qui était à 600
ou 700 millions d'euros il a été il a
été voté et il n'a pas été retenu par le
gouvernement là ce sont des choses très
concrètes pour la vie de nos concitoyens
et plus largement la future indemnité
carburant qu'on va avoir à partir de
janvier est-ce que c'est pas vous ce que
vous proposiez il y a un petit peu plus
d'un an c'est à dire l'idée d'une
indemnité carburant pour ceux qui
travaillent pas pour tous les Français
pour les pour les grands rouleurs qui
ont besoin de la voiture pour travailler
est-ce que vous n'avez pas obtenu gain
de cause je sais pas si j'ai obtenu une
grande cause ou pas toujours est-il
on entend la philosophie de la mesure en
tout cas ça serait ça mais moi je suis
pour que les aides soient ciblées vers
celles et ceux qui en ont plus besoin
donc là dessus je pourrais je sais pas
exactement ce que le profil et quels
sont les seuils qui vont être définies
par le gouvernement parce que je préfère
toujours regarder les choses avant oui
oui vous avez sur le cocorico quand même
vous avez sur le 10h vous avez dit ah
ben voilà je l'avais demandé maintenant
et finalement mais
c'est un peu ce gouvernement je peux
vous donner aussi toute une série de
propositions que nous avions faites qui
ont été balayés refusés et puis on les
voit fleurir 6 mois un an après bon
voilà c'est finalement c'est le
gouvernement écoute
finalement vous obtenez gain de cause
non mais alors si vos idées sont
reprises c'est moi je suis toujours
contente que les idées soient reprises
par contre la paternité ou la maternité
elle est rarement attribue à leurs
auteurs mais enfin on n'est pas là pour
faire du cocorico on est là pour que les
choses avancent mais ce que je reproche
au gouvernement c'est pourquoi il nous a
pas écouté il y a un an vous avez parce
que aujourd'hui on est face à une
situation oui il avait une majorité
absolue faisait ce qu'il voulait donne
politique a changé oui mais sans doute
mais on peut aussi avoir comme objectif
l'intérêt général l'intérêt du pays
faire en sorte que on aide celles et
ceux qui ont le plus besoin sans
forcément faire des chèques en blanc
avec une dette abyssale qui augmente et
un déficit qui augmente alors je sais
que les finances publiques n'intéressent
personne j'en ai bien compris moi elle
m'intéresse parce que on se fait
toujours frappé par la dette et celles
et ces personnes c'est le gouvernement
qui dépense sans compter et sans faire
attention le gouvernement et puis enfin
même dans le débat public il y a quand
même rarement quelqu'un qui va vous dire
les finances publiques c'est intéressant
parce que ça dit des choses et bien oui
ça dit des choses de la manière dont on
voit aussi le futur de notre pays est-ce
qu'on veut kiffer qui va payer est-ce
que ce sont les jeunes générations enfin
tout ça ça dit beaucoup de choses sur
peut-être notre égoïsme personnel ou pas
mais je pense que ça on aurait intérêt à
le traité je reviens une demi seconde
sur la motion de censure vous avez dit
ça sert à rien on n'aura pas les voix
j'avais cru comprendre que le groupe
socialiste était prêt en déposer une et
en signer une avec l'ensemble de la nuit
pour une lecture définitive projet de
loi de finances ou projet de financement
de la sécurité sociale vous me confirmez
ou pas le faire une fois pour vraiment
marquer
la fin d'un processus sur le
débat budgétaire c'est un sens oui et à
ce moment là oui mais des fois en en
faisant je sais pas 14 15 je pense pense
que la banaliser n'est pas dans
l'intérêt démocratie donc vous assurer
la dernière lecture de l'année finale
on verra mais effectivement l'idée c'est
qu'on puisse avoir sur la dernière
lecture véritablement ben voilà on a une
vision globale vision globale du la
notion de censure
que que ça aboutisse
mais déjà on va voir comment il sera
écrites vous savez moi je fais jamais de
chèques en blanc
alors en termes de pouvoir d'achat on va
parler d'autres chèques c'est le chèque
énergie qui a été décidé par le
gouvernement il y a aussi une aide pour
le boite 50 à 200 euros il y a la
ristourne à la pompe qui qui continue
quand même et puis il y a le bouclier
tarifaire on peut pas dire que le
gouvernement fait rien vous vous saluez
ces gestes là vous trouvez qu'il y en a
assez pour le pouvoir d'achat
alors sur la question de l'énergie
moi je suis assez en colère que on
continue à payer l'électricité aussi
chère parce que ce que vous me dites là
c'est que on met des aides publiques
pour compenser un prix qui est devenu
mais stratosphérique sur l'électricité
l'électricité vous savez moi j'ai une
centrale nucléaire dans mon département
un Golfech quand elle sort elle coûte 47
euros le mégawh et quand on va aller la
racheter quand des industriels vont leur
acheter ou des entreprises ou non on est
entre 350 et 500 euros le mégawh donc il
y a des gens qui s'enrichissent en fait
ça
et que le gouvernement ne tape pas du
point sur la table quand il va à
Bruxelles pour dire ça a été fait non
bah pourquoi les Espagnols les Portugal
ils sont arrivés et pas la France
posez-vous la question de sortir du
marché d'électricité mais posez-vous la
question est-ce qu'il y a un accord avec
l'Allemagne mais il y a évidemment ce
qu'il faut balancer l'accord avec
l'Allemagne pour payer moins cher notre
électricité il y a un accord avec
l'Allemagne sur la provisionnement en
électricité pourquoi mais les Allemands
sont pas du tout contents avec nous
quand on va aller voir ils nous disent
vous voulez du nucléaire très bien mais
vous avez la moitié de vos centrales qui
fonctionnent pas la moitié donc ça les
Allemands nous le disent clairement ils
ont pas tort on fait des choix on n'est
pas capable de les assumer le problème
d'EDF c'est le problème du Google le
problème de DF c'est le problème du
gouvernement ça fait cinq ans de
plusieurs gouvernements success oui mais
enfin en tout cas le gouvernement était
quand même en poste pendant 5 ans
pendant 5 ans on a le temps de faire des
choses et là-dessus vous voyez bien que
DF n'a pas assez investi que on lui a
demandé des dividendes moi j'avais ce
que j'avais mis plusieurs fois dans les
rapports qu'il fallait que on puisse
discuter des versements dividendes et
qui t'ont pas systématiquement dans le
budget général de l'État
donc ces questions là continuez à avoir
appris l'électricité indexé sur le gaz
ne pas faire comme ce qu'on fait
l'Espagne et le Portugal dès le mois de
mai ne pas être arrivé à le faire c'est
une faute majeure parce que ça veut dire
que vous utilisez l'argent public pour
compenser un prix qui est délirant
deuxième sujet aider les collectivités
locales sur des moi je vous donner un
exemple d'une commune petite commune
chez moi puis cornée qui a mis qui a
fait la géothermie vous mettez six pieds
à 150 m dans la terre et bien vous
chauffez votre école vous chauffez la
mairie vous chauffez les logements
municipaux ça ça doit être accompagné
beaucoup plus par l'État et bien les
petites communes elles se débrouillent
toute seule les énergies toutes seules
et ça c'est un vrai sujet et sur les
énergies renouvelables la France est le
seul pays parmi les 27 de l'Union
européenne à ne pas avoir atteint ses
objectifs de production d'énergie
renouveau alors justement il y a un
projet de loi pour accélérer sur les
énergies renouvelables
il y a quand même plusieurs alors mais
c'est un texte qui a été adopté au Sénat
avec les voix de la gauche avec les
voies socialistes avec les voies
écologistes est-ce que ici à l'Assemblée
vous allez le voter de débats et la
semaine prochaine donc est-ce que vous
avez une position il a déjà eu un
commission oui il a eu en commission
mais les débats vous savez il y a des
moments les débats bougent dans
l'hémicycle ça sert à ça sinon si tout
était écrit d'avance bah il vaut mieux
alors vous en êtes où
il faut qu'il y ait nous on avait
demandé une programmation qui soit enfin
voilà qui soit crédible qui soit lisible
aujourd'hui vous êtes
donc je vais toujours reprendre
l'exemple du Tarn-et-Garonne vous avez
des locaux des bâtiments logistiques qui
s'installent pas un seul panneau
photovoltaïque alors qu'on est un des
départements les plus ensoleillés de
France quand vous avez un jeune
agriculteur qui s'installe qui demande
de pouvoir faire un hangar de 500 mètres
carrés justement parce que les recours
sont trop longs ce texte va permettre de
la préfecture lui refuse c'est parce que
la préfecture lui refuse et qui la
préfecture c'est l'état en disant Vané
mégoter sur le nombre de mètres carrés
qui veut mettre sur son toit pour mettre
du flou
donc c'est ça que la loi doit changer
mais vous rendez la loi le fait-elle la
vous vous rendez compte que il y a eu
des avancées notamment des amendements
qui ont été déposés sur ce point-là mais
vous rendez compte que on est parfois on
se dit qu'on est dans un pays absurde
absurde avec des objectifs qui sont
indiqués au niveau national et puis
après sur le terrain c'est refusé pour
ne pas le voter
si justement ça accélère l'installation
du photovoltaïque et de toutes ces
énergies renouvelables le PS ne peut pas
ne pas le voter tout ça on le soutient
mais vous me demandez ce qui sera le
texte final donc là la semaine prochaine
il y a un débat évidemment sur toutes
ces avancées nous les soutenons nous les
demandons je vous ai donné deux trois
exemples très précis mais il faut qu'il
y ait une programmation qui permet de
donner la lisibilité à chacun et pas
qu'il y ait de l'arbitrage
parce que l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
donc la semaine la dernière ce texte qui
constitutionnalise l'IVG est-ce que vous
demandez au Sénat de faire de même
d'adopter ce texte sachant que le Sénat
a refusé un texte assez similaire qui
voulait aussi la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG oui alors c'est une très grande
avancée qui a été faite la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale la
formulation qui a été retenue grâce à un
amendement de Monsieur balanand et de
Marie-Noëlle batistel qui ont permis de
dans le fond de le faire que le vote
voilà que le vote puisse avoir lieu avec
une formulation qui soit positive et qui
donne des garanties notamment par la loi
sur la durée et que ce soit mis dans le
texte que ce soit donc ça c'est vraiment
été l'inversion de l'écriture qui a
permis le vote et un vote très très
largement
historique donc on n'est pas obligé de
faire la même chose je dis au Sénat mais
reprenez ce texte parce que il met des
garanties dans la Constitution et il
précise bien que notamment sur la durée
sur les conditions c'est la loi mais le
Sénat du l'IVG n'est pas menacé en
France il y a pas besoin de le mettre
dans la Constitution
est-ce que ils ont tort
mais il est pas menacé aujourd'hui même
si aucun groupe ne dit aujourd'hui
on peut aussi porter une voix qui
dépasse un peu nos frontières merci
infiniment Brigitte Etam
ira bon on va se tourner maintenant vers
Jean-Baptiste sémardian du figurant du
figarolive bonsoir Jean-Baptiste merci
d'être avec nous il est ici voilà il est
là votre interlocuteur vous avez choisi
comme question d'actualité tiens un
départ du gouvernement il y a quelques
heures Jean-Baptiste et oui Elisabeth
effectivement aujourd'hui Emmanuel
Macron a mis fin aux fonctions de
Caroline Cayeux qui était ministre
délégué au collectivités territoriales
cet après-midi sur Twitter elle a réagi
l'ancienne ministre elle affirme avoir
quitté son poste à la suite d'un
désaccord avec la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique qui
estime que sa déclaration de patrimoine
serait sous-estimée comment est-ce que
vous réagissez à cette démission et
est-ce qu'elle a eu raison de démission
écoutez je ne réagis pas je n'en sais
rien j'ai vu son tweet voilà
est-ce que vous trouvez que c'est pour
le gouvernement
de faire en sorte qu'une ministre qu'il
n'a pas trouvé un accord avec la Haute
Autorité
des qui demandent des déclarations de
patrimoine et de revenus je trouvais que
c'est plutôt cohérent c'est plutôt sain
non mais cette autorité c'est bon
s'impose elle s'impose à tout le monde
ce qui est très bien ministre élu aux
fonctionnaires donc je connais pas la
nature des discussions qui qu'elle a eu
avec la Haute Autorité voilà j'ai juste
vu son tweet et alors et ça vous a fait
aucun effet non politiquement de toute
façon ça ne change rien et par ailleurs
ça la regarde ça regarde le gouvernement
nous on n'a pas je dis pas politiquement
si vous me demandez politiquement sur sa
situation je n'en sais rien donc je vais
pas vous répondre là dessus et
l'équilibre pour le gouvernement
écoutez bon je pense que toute façon je
vais être on sait très bien les
décisions sur les collectivités locales
seront la main du président de la
République et d'autres donc je suis pas
sûr que ça change grand chose
donc pas d'effet merci beaucoup à tout à
l'heure Jean-Baptiste pour une autre
question d'actualité Sophie Ravinel
c'est assise en face de vous bonjour
Sophie bonjour spécialiste en
particulier des questions relatives à la
gauche au Figaro il y a un congrès dans
quelques semaines congrès alors Valérie
Rimbault c'est à vous alors est-ce qu'il
concerne Valérie bosser la question on
appelle beaucoup ce congrès le Congrès
clandestin il y avait samedi dernier une
présentation clandestin parce que il
passe un tout petit peu pour l'instant
sous les radars des médias mais
peut-être que vous allez nous aider à
éliminer un peu tout ça samedi dernier
il y avait un rassemblement de tous les
cadres socialistes pour présenter les
trois principales orientations un de ce
congrès avec Olivier Faure très
globalement Hélène Jouffroy et Nicolas
Meyer rossignol qui sont les trois
personnalités principales vous n'étiez
pas à la présentation de ces motion vous
êtes très rarement là quand il s'agit de
l'organisation du parti
pour qu'elle pour quelle raison alors
moi j'ai toujours je suis très attachée
aux parties socialiste vous ne le vous
ne leur montrerez pas concrètement oui
mais donc ça c'est le premier point j'ai
d'ailleurs été première secrétaire
fédérale dans le Tarn-et-Garonne donc je
j'attache beaucoup d'importance aux
militantisme ou des bas d'idées et au
fait que on puisse véritablement
organiser une aussi une démocratie
locale si vous voulez que je vous donne
le fond de ma pensée je pense que les
partis politiques sont en train de
mourir
qui servent aujourd'hui
essentiellement pour des ingérer des
questions de financement de partie de
financement de campagne et quand même un
point important ce qui est un point très
important mais je ne c'est pour ça je le
sous-estime pas je vous dis que leur
utilité est peut-être
et je le regrette en revanche pour ce
qui est des grands débats d'idées de
savoir comment on y régle la société
comment on est capable de dans le fond
de sentir le pouls de la société le
transformer en caps politiques ou en
programme je pense que il n'y arrive
plus il n'y arrive plus parce qu'il ne
travaille pas assez parce que les
oliviers forts
politiques en général moi je vous
interroge sur le parc oui donc vous le
mettez c'est la même chose voilà je
pense que ça fait 10 ans que le Parti
socialiste malheureusement n'a pas été
en capacité de
véritablement porter une idée j'observe
que les propositions qui ont été
d'ailleurs portées dans les campagnes
présidentielles et législatives elles
ont toutes émané des groupes
parlementaires et ce qui est pas
forcément
donc vous vous envoyez
les sénateurs qui portent des idées vous
avez quand le revenu de base a été porté
ben c'est 19 Présidents de Conseils
départementaux socialistes qui les ont
qui l'ont imaginé qui ont organisé une
consultation avec 15000 citoyens ça
s'était en Gironde c'est jean-luclée le
président du conseil départemental de la
Gironde c'est vraiment des idées qui qui
émergent du terrain et je regrette que
les grands courants de pensée ne soient
plus portés par les parties donc c'est
aussi pour ça que vous vous prenez juste
pour prolonger la question de Sophie
effectivement vous êtes très intéressé
par pâtisserie très intéressé par ce qui
se passe vous n'y êtes pas très engagé
vous êtes toujours assez prudente est-ce
que vous avez envie de rentrer un peu
davantage dans combat dans la danse vous
allez voter et vous allez participer à
ce congrès pour l'instant j'ai signé
aucun texte oui voilà est-ce que ça va
changer
vous savez moi j'aimerais que les textes
donnent des grandes orientations sur
vous savez le Parti socialiste il a été
capable de faire vivre en son sein la
gauche Dorian magnoli et l'associal
démocratie qui est quand même plus sur
l'aile droite du parti socialiste et
c'est à chaque fois comme ça que le
Parti socialiste a gagné des élections
aujourd'hui il y a des questions qui se
posent est-ce que dans le fond on
affirme qu'on est pour ou contre la
croissance et quelle croissance moi je
suis contre la décroissance parce que je
pense que la croissance c'est la
pauvreté du pays c'est un
appauvrissement généralisé fort ne parle
pas de décroissances pas encore en tout
cas mais parce que cette question est
même pas posée alors qu'elle devrait
être tranchée est-ce que oui ou non on
est on veut la raison contre le
populisme et comment ça se traduit et
donc ça est-ce que les valeurs de la
République est-ce que les d'un point
essentiel de ce Congrès et du coup mais
Nicolas Maillard rossignol qui est sur
la ligne intermédiaire se transforme en
congrès en disant il y a ceux qui sont
pour la nuque et ceux qui seraient
antillais la voix intermédiaire qui est
celle de Nicolas meilleur
c'est un enjeu de stratégie ça doit pas
être un enjeu dans le fond de ce qu'est
le cap du Parti social c'est aussi un
enjeu d'idée parce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon ce n'est pas qu'une stratégie
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous-même
que vous lui reconnaissiez effectivement
mais des idées mais je reconnais
beaucoup d'idées à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais si on est d'accord avec ses idées
on va à la France insoumise donc vous
dites à Olivier fort qui devrait
appartenir à la France insoumise
je ne dis pas Olivier fort qui devrait
appartenir la France insoumise je suis
en train de vous parler du Parti
socialiste
socialiste a pour moi trois grandes
questions à régler pour pouvoir incarner
véritablement un cap donc je vais les
redire est-ce qu'on est pour ou contre
la décroissance moi je suis contre la
décroissance je suis pour une croissance
parce que je considère que l'esprit
humain est infini et que ce génie humain
et bien c'est ce qui permet le progrès
vous savez Camus disait créer c'est
vivre deux fois et bien il vaut mieux
vivre de foi il vaut mieux être en
capacité de créer et ça un parti
politique doit l'incarner ou en tout cas
une ligne politique
évidemment ça vous honore mais la
politique aussi ce sont des choix et des
fois tranchés parfois d'incarnation les
gens se congrès il y a pour ou contre
Olivier fort il y a trois motions dans
deux qui sont en opposition et
qu'Olivier fort êtes-vous en opposition
et Coline je pense que c'est pas ça
qu'on attend du Parti socialiste vous me
posez je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
je pensais que les parties aucune depuis
10 ans
j'ai pas dit qu'il y avait pas des
stratégie électorale ne fait pas dire ce
que j'ai pas dit je vous dis que je
l'avais pas sur la production d'idées je
pense que il y en a pas eu qui émane du
parti depuis 10 ans il y en a qui ont
émané des groupes avec plus ou moins
succès mais donc il faudrait renouveler
et donc vous êtes pour eux un
remplacement d'Olivier fort je suis pour
que on tranche des questions depuis
combien de temps les minions ne tranchez
pas notre question c'est bien dit mais
d'abord le vote ce mois de janvier
je vous ai dit que je n'avais signé
aucun texte j'avais signé une tribune
hier c'était bien pour compter dans le
comté dans ce contact mais pas forcément
quand je vous dis que les partis
politiques c'est vous savez hier j'ai
entendu Sandrine Rousseau dire il y
avait 100.000 votants à la primaire des
Verts et 5000 et bien je pense qu'elle a
raison et je pense que les partis
politiques sont en train de mourir et
que donc l'offre de politique de l'offre
politique de dans le fond de comment on
interagit avec la société
ça va sans doute se passer ailleurs à
propos d'Olivier Faure il a réagi tout
de suite et assez nettement quand Adrien
katnas sur la il y a eu de nouvelles
révélations concernant le cas de
d'Adrien catenin c'est compliqué mais
des histoires de violence conjugales
avec son épouse dont il est en train de
se séparer qui est venu contredire les
propos à lui affirmant qu'il n'y avait
aucune gifle etc elle disant qu'il y
avait eu beaucoup plus de pluie beaucoup
plus d'années et donc la justice
tranchera le 13 décembre d'ici là
Olivier fort a appelé à à ce qu'il ne
revienne pas à l'assemblée qui ne puisse
plus siéger vous êtes d'accord au moins
sur ce point avec la réforme
vous aussi vous pensez qu'il ne devrait
pas siéger ah oui je pense qu'il de
toute façon c'est moi décembre je pense
qu'il faut qu'il attende le jugement
qu'il attend le jugement mais que d'ici
là il peut revenir non non je pense je
partage la position d'Olivier fort sur
ce droit par revenir attendre le
jugement vous ne dites il n'est plus en
capacité quoi qu'il en soit ayant admis
avoir donné une gifle de représenter je
pense que il faut que chacun reste dans
son rôle les juges sont les juges les
députés il y a une séparation des
pouvoirs ne sont pas les juges vous avez
été surprise un peu par le fait que chez
les insoumis ce soit uniquement le
groupe qui communique et qui disent il
est urgent d'attendre sans se prononcer
est-ce que vous y voyez un peu
l'influence de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et un
fonctionnement particulier un peu
spécifique aux insoumis
vous les voyez travailler tous les jours
oui vous portez un jugement sur la façon
dont leur groupe mais je commente
fonctionne non parce que si vous voulez
que je oui je vous ai parlé beaucoup du
Parti socialiste je peux vous parler du
groupe mais je vais pas parler des
autres alors justement Clémentine Notin
elle appelle un travail inter-groupe à
trouver une charte qui soit commune
avant de parler groupe ou pas avant de
la nu je pense justement ça peut être un
bon moyen de faire vivre la nuque oui
avant de parler d'intergroupe je pense
que chacun peut déjà faire vivre son
groupe et puis les bonnes pratiques les
bonnes pratiques peuvent être partagées
mais je pense que avant de vouloir faire
des des règles pour l'inter-groupe et
bien que chacun fait vise va fasse vivre
son groupe dernière question peut-être
sur Paris Anne Hidalgo peut-être que
vous allez la soutenir par ce congrès
parce que elle est en fait derrière la
liste de Nicolas Mayer Rossignol elle
est très attaquée en ce moment par le
gouvernement par des représentants du
gouvernement sur la gestion de la ville
vous qui est spécialiste des politiques
publiques et ce que vous comprenez ces
attaques est-ce que vous soutenez la
gestion de la dette par Anne Hidalgo et
la gestion de sa ville globalement alors
j'observe il y a beaucoup d'attaques
politiques de la part de potentiel
prétendants à la candidature prochaine
municipale je sais pas comment ils
s'organise entre eux mais enfin en tout
cas bon on voit bien qu'il y a eu des
petites passes d'armes ils sont nombreux
je pense que la question
effectivement budgétaire et financière
évidemment pour la ville de Paris est
importante puisque il y a les JO qui
arrivent qui demandent aussi des choix
et je pense aussi que
de ce que je comprends c'est que l'État
n'a pas totalement continue tous ces
engagements alors si je regarde après
sur les transports notamment parce que
c'est quand même ce qui coûte cher et
bien quand on regarde depuis 7-8 ans on
investissait globalement en France un
peu plus de 1% de notre PIB chaque année
pour les transports on est à 0,8 alors
vous allez me dire oui entre 1 et 0,8
oui mais enfin ça fait tout de suite 6
milliards d'euros en moins un an donc il
y a quand même eu des
sous-investissement sur les transports
et ça on sait que c'est aussi ce qui
coûte cher est-ce que le principe de
récupérer cette année de loyer comme l'a
fait Anne Hidalgo qui a été dénoncé
alors très vite par un système Gabriel
Attal comme un système de Ponzi mais ce
principe là qui est un principe d'une
règle budgétaire est-ce que vous la
prouvez ou est-ce que c'était imprudent
mais ça a été validé par le ministère de
l'Économie des Finances puisque pour une
bonne pour cette raison là quand on
signe il faut être deux à minima donc
j'imagine indépendant ça de
l'incohérence que vous dénoncez est-ce
que comme règle budgétaire c'est prudent
et prudent
je connais pas le texte exactement ce
qu'elle a signé moi je pense que il vaut
toujours mieux avoir une comptabilité
qui correspondent aux années
effectivement
ça c'est un principe global mais à
partir du moment où Bercy a signé Bercy
doit respecter sa signature sinon ça
veut dire qu'un contrat n'a plus de
valeur donc c'est une responsabilité
partagée ah bah c'est bien sûr une
responsabilité partagée parce que pour
signer un contrat il faut être deux
merci beaucoup Sophie Ravinel dans un
instant le sénateur René Paul ça va
arriver à nous rejoindre il va beaucoup
vous parler de retraite une question
quand même parce que les images
évidemment sont absolument sidérantes
sont les manifestations historiques en
Chine on voit que des milliers
d'habitants de différentes villes
chinoises
manifestent contre la politique zéro
covid
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire dans le
fond m'inspire deux choses ça inspire
que nous avons beaucoup de chance
d'avoir le vaccin
et d'aide vaccinées et ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas de la population
chinoise et donc nous mesurons la chance
que nous avons de pouvoir sortir en
liberté
franchement quand on voit ces images ça
nous interpelle et ça doit nous faire
prendre conscience de notre propre
liberté et le deuxième volet qui est
évidemment plus démocratique c'est que
effectivement le peuple chinois ça peut
être un vrai tournant pour pour le
pouvoir central en place en Chine entre
la révolte des femmes en Iran cette
colère chinoise tout à fait inédite
et même cette résistance absolument
fantastique qu'on admire beaucoup des
Ukrainiens face à Poutine il y a quelque
chose à la fois sur ce fond dramatique
absolu de dictatures il y a quelque
chose de réconfortant il y a quelque
chose il y a une force humaine
incroyable j'ai eu l'occasion d'aller en
Ukraine avec la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons
rencontré des gens qui ont leur maison
détruite nous avons rencontré le
président qui a une force intérieure
pour voilà tenir le pays et ce combat et
donc ça c'est un enseignement chaque
jour de cette force humaine incroyable
René Paul savarier est en face de vous
je peux vous appeler monsieur retraite
vous êtes sénateur à l'air de la Marne
monsieur retraite du Sénat voilà non non
pas encore et vous avez choisi
effectivement de d'aborder ce débat je
vous remercie de l'avoir accepté
d'ailleurs tous les deux sur ce sujet
qui va beaucoup occuper le Parlement
dans quelques semaines et qui va être
très important aussi pour le
gouvernement vous avez vous-même je
crois été l'auteur d'un amendement ou
sinon qui porte là je les gars la 64 ans
voilà pour être précise monsieur Savary
c'est à VOUS bah écoutez oui c'est un
sujet qui paraît important je crois que
c'est incontestable non seulement pour
le gouvernement mais pour l'ensemble des
Français simplement la situation on la
connaît quand même par rapport aux
autres pays on part à un âge beaucoup
plus avancé que nos voisins européens on
a un nombre de cotisants par rapport au
nombre de retraités qui est en train de
se dégrader et il sera un moment
important de prendre des mesures et si
on prend pas les mesures tout de suite
elles seront d'autant plus brutales
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
poussons le gouvernement en tout cas la
majorité sénatoriale dont je fais partie
apprend le ses responsabilités en
partant sur un certain nombre de de
principes que sûrement vous partagez
pour certains notamment à faire
confiance aux partenaires sociaux et la
discussion elle doit pas être sur un
coin de table pendant deux trois mois
elle doit s’établir au moins sur un an
avec un principe également que si on
prend pas tout de suite les mesures les
réformes feront qu'on travaille qu'on
travaillera encore plus longtemps plus
de 65 ans nous on préfère que l'âge soit
ramené à 64 plutôt que 65 et puis on
veut surtout affirmer que le système de
répartition c'est un système qui par
définition dans son financement ne peut
pas être équilibré par la dette donc il
faut prendre mesure d'équilibre à
travers cette réforme d'autant plus
qu'il y a un certain nombre de mesures
de solidarité qui doivent être
accompagnants toutes ces dispositifs et
qu'il faut bien trouver les financements
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
proposé des mesures paramétriques et
d'ajustement notamment de l'âge avec un
âge de départ de l'âge légal à 64 ans au
lieu de 62 et en accélérant la réforme
Touraine que vous connaissez bien et qui
s'appliquera à partir de 1967 au lieu de
la génération pour commencer
je voulais préciser ça pour qu'on voit
ce que l'on peut partager et ma question
quelle est la position actuellement que
vous avez par rapport à cela puisque
vous avez au fil du temps refuser le
décalage de l'âge tout en acceptant
réforme Touraine la durée plus longue
des cotisations alors
il y a eu effectivement c'est le seul
quinquennat celui qui vient de s'achever
qui n'a pas fait de réforme des
retraites puisque président Sarkozy en
avait fait une lui il avait à la fois
augmenté l'âge de départ à la retraite
et la durée de cotisation ensuite il y a
eu en 2013 2014 la réforme Touraine qui
a augmenté la durée de cotisation avec
un ajustement sur les cotisations et
puis le précédent quinquennat où il n'y
a rien eu du tout bon moi je suis contre
partir sur une réforme qui fixe l'âge
parce que si vous commencez à travailler
très tôt vous avez vos annuités vous
n'avez pas encore atteint l'âge et vous
commencez par rapport à d'autres si vous
commencez à travailler très tôt c'est
qu'en général vous n'avez pas eu des
études prolongées et souvent s'aperçoit
que ce sont aussi les salaires qui sont
les moins élevés donc moi je suis contre
cette cette question cette question sur
l'âge là où je vous rejoins c'est que je
pense pas que équilibrer un système des
retraites avec la dette soit une bonne
chose mais quand je regarde alors pareil
quand je regarde les équilibres
effectivement 4 milliards 8 de déficits
du régime général en 2012 la réforme
Touraine permet d'amener le système à
l'équilibre
ça dépend des hypothèses qu'on prend sur
le taux de chômage etc
mais moi je pense que s'il y a un vrai
débat sur les retraites plutôt que
demander de dire on va passer à 65 ans
moi je suis contre ou à 74 de dire aux
Français est-ce que vous préférez passer
à 64 ans ou est-ce que vous pourriez
préférer payer puisque c'est ça le
montant entre 11 et 22 euros de plus par
mois sur les cotisations qui peuvent
être aussi prises en charge par les
employeurs ça ça peut être un vrai débat
parce que je suis pas sûr que ce soit
suffisant quand même ça serait un vrai
débat plutôt que de dire c'est tout tout
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième sujet sur la durée de
cotisation sur ce sujet peut-être la
difficulté c'est une différence parce
que la durée de cotisation qui augmente
si inéluctable de toute façon la réforme
va faire que on va en arriver là
simplement sur le plan de de du poids
budgétaire que cela entraîne c'est c'est
minime si vous décalez pas l'âge
pourquoi vous avez 20 ans vous avez 43
annuités ce que propose ça fait 63 ans
si l'âge légal est mis à 64 ans il y a
beaucoup de personnes qui vont dire à ce
moment-là si je peux partir si vous
décalez pas l'âge légal ils partent et
ils n'ont pas forcément puisque là s'il
y a une reste à 62 ans ils n'ont pas
forcément leur retraite à taux plein
donc vous faites automatiquement des
travailleurs les scénarios sont
là-dessus très classique la réforme de
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
fait qu'il y a une baisse de la pension
moyenne on déclarez
oui oui de 300 euros en moyenne en
moyenne et la réforme de l'âge fait que
ça augmente le niveau de retraite c'est
la raison pour laquelle dans la
stabilité du système et pour l'équilibre
sur le long terme il faut faire un
mariage et de sinon c'est pas suffisant
madame la retraite ce n'est pas qu'un
équilibre budgétaire c'est aussi ça
apporte ce que ça dit pour la vie de nos
concitoyens quelqu'un qui a commencé à
travailler à 19 ans ou quelqu'un qui a
commencé à travailler à 25 ans vous lui
dites vous allez partir tous les deux au
même âge vous vouloir fixer une retraite
un départ d'âge à la retraite à 64 ans
de dispositifs
uniquement sur la durée de cotisation
parce que comme ça vous êtes plus juste
vis-à-vis de la personne qui est partie
à 19 ans parce que les gens partiront
plus tôt si vous restez un âge légal ils
vont dire ben je pars à la Lège les gars
je ne pars pas l'âge du temps plein
d'utoplin heureusement les gens pour le
taux plein c'est important parce que
déjà il faut que la retraite elle soit
conséquente les difficultés
du niveau de retraite pour partir à taux
plein s'il le souhaite au-delà de 62
après c'est pas la même chose pour les
taux plein et quand on calcule la
retraite c'est ce que vous touchez à ce
jour-là la durée moyenne des retraites
une vingtaine d'années la moyenne avec
toutes les difficultés qu'on connaît
mais on sait très bien qu'il y a pas la
revalorisation qui suit donc où vous
avez l'impression quand vous prenez
votre retraite que vous êtes à peu près
un niveau moyen par rapport à vous dites
ça va suffire sauf que 10 15 ans après
ça suffit et vous faites des personnes
qui connaissent des difficultés c'est
quand même redoutable je trouve comme
système qui a commencé à travailler à 19
ans vous allez partir à 64 ans quelqu'un
qui a travaillé commençait à travailler
à 25 ans parce qu'il a fait des études
qui a un salaire plus élevé vous lui
mettez le même âge mais c'est
mais oui au 19 ans 25 ans
de retraite anticipée pour carrière
longue vous l'ajuster en fonction c'est
quand même ça c'est ça existe ça
vous partez de la durée de cotisation
que vous introduisez de la pénibilité
parce que quand vous faites des métiers
du des publics vous avez une pénibilité
sur le port de charge on parle du
travail des seniors c'est important et
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
c'est deux leviers durée de cotisation
et pénibilité pour nous ce sont les deux
gens qui permettent d'avoir une réforme
des retraites juste et vous vous êtes
sur l'âge de départ à la retraite ce qui
pour moi est injuste pour payer la
pénibilité il faut bien équilibrer le
système nous nous voulons une vraie
solidarité c'est pour ça que c'est pour
ça que il faut pouvoir la financer la
solidarité on est d'accord mais vous
pouvez ce sont des dépenses
supplémentaires
vous pouvez la fin là vous voulez la
financer sur les cotisations retraite la
pénibilité sans augmenter
vous pouvez imaginer une solidarité qui
soigne solidarité nationale par exemple
si on remet l'ISF ça peut financer la
solidarité et on est plutôt sur une
solidarité qui soit de justice sociale
plutôt que celle que vous proposez mais
notre système n'est pas injuste notre
système est un système qui permet
justement de maintenir les gens en
employeur il y a rien de pire et on a
d'abord
partir à 64 ans et quelqu'un qui a de
commencer à travailler à 25 ans partira
64 ans et celui qui a commencé
à 64 ans
justement ceux qui ont travaillé plus
tôt parle plutôt
en ligne de compte c'est la durée de
cotisations il y a la durée de
cotisations
les emplois seniors en emploi
nous c'est notre philosophie en pensant
que plus il y a de personnes en emploi
plus ça crée des richesses plus on sera
les jeunes c'est la raison pour laquelle
on est attaché à ce maintien de l'emploi
des seniors il faut surtout pas qui
quitte leur travail il faut pas que ce
soit la variable d'ajustement il faut
miser sur les seniors c'est ce qu'on
avait conclu et avec des dispositifs
qu'on peut améliorer et je pense que
vous en partagez certains puisque vous
aviez essayé les contrats de générations
c'est notamment la retraite progressive
ou encore progressive cumule emploi
retraite qui permet de travailler les
trois jours et puis de commencer à
partir de jours à la retraite par
semaine qui est de la flexibilité avant
c'était pas possible parce qu'il y avait
pas de système informatique aujourd'hui
tout est informatisé on peut avoir une
un système qui soit plus facilitant pour
l'ensemble des voilà c'est pour ça que
en jouant sur ces paramètres il y a
toujours une année qui peut être ou deux
années qui peuvent être plutôt une année
entre 63 et 64 ans qui pourraient
critique si on décalage et c'est là
qu'il faut trouver que l'on propose
justement qui est des mesures
particulières pour qu'il y ait une
entrée en retraite progressive qu'on
arrête en France de liquider
définitivement sa retraite on part en
retraite et en fin de compte c'est fini
non il faut pouvoir liquider de façon
intermédiaire continuer si possible
d'avoir un travail faire l'équilibre que
éventuellement des cotisations
supplémentaires qui rentrent en ligne de
compte puisque c'est pas pris
actuellement qui rentre en ligne de
compte dans ce cumulat et la question
qu'on peut vous poser puisque c'est vous
qui n'aviez pas accepté enfin la gauche
qui n'avait pas accepté à l'époque que
les cotisations
droit donne ouvre des droits en ce qui
concerne le cumul emploi retraite moi je
pense que c'est quelque chose sur lequel
il faut revenir vous aussi moi je suis
favorable à ce qui peut y avoir un cumul
mais je redis je suis en défaveur du
report de l'âge légal de la
je préfère le préciser
mais là-dessus qu'il puisse y avoir un
aménagement pour augmenter parce
qu'effectivement on a 10 points de moins
en moyenne du taux de travail des
seniors par rapport au reste de l'Union
européenne oui facilement à peu près 10
mois voilà et donc le faciliter ça vous
êtes d'accord mais moi je suis issue
favorable oui d'accord bah voilà voilà
je pense qu'il faut bien faire
comprendre à nos concitoyens que c'est
légitime que l'on est un maintien le
plus longtemps possible dans l'emploi et
ça permet en même temps de lutter contre
les troubles cognitifs etc ça aussi des
avantages en tout cas débat très
instructif ce serait bien que au
Parlement y est ce même genre d'échanges
parce que vous étiez passionnant tous
les deux vous pensez que ça sera le cas
on verra je sais pas ce que donnera ce
qui sera proposé dans la réforme du
calendrier
mais je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
l'urgence de faire cette réforme des
retraites moi je pense que dans les
urgences il y a l'énergie et que on va
se prendre une crise
sans doute au début de l'année prochaine
si le gouvernement ne corrige pas cette
question sur l'énergie enfin je vais
revenir sur ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure quand vous voyez que un
boulanger dans ma circonscription d'une
petite commune va passer d'une facture
de 1500 euros à 4500 euros par mois mais
ça veut dire quoi donc si s'il y a pas
cette question là de l'énergie qui est
résolue très rapidement on va le
gouvernement risque de laisser mettre au
tapis n'est pas en économie et une
commune qui a plus de boulangerie c'est
pas possible dans un instant on va
retrouver Jean-Baptiste et merdjan 49,3
sur la réforme des retraites qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
dans ce cas le gouvernement
utilisera sa dernière cartouche
d'Emmanuel Macron qui est que la réforme
rentre en vigueur à l'été 2023
il peut aussi le faire dans le cadre du
projet de budget
rectificatif la sécurité sociale mais je
crois que c'est engagé pas le faire donc
non pour vous et non mais en tout cas
vous dites que les engagements
je peux pas parler
une réforme des retraites ça doit être
une réforme des retraites ça peut pas
être un amendement ou un article dans un
projet de loi de la sécurité sociale
il y a moyen de parer en prenant les
mesures désagréables notamment les
mesures d'âge à travers impérielle à
faire puisque
toutes les modalités sociales à côté de
ça prise d'accord
le Parlement ne va plus servir à rien la
France ne sera plus une démocratie tout
passera en 49,3 on regardera plus les
articles les amandes les amendements ne
seront plus retenus
Jean-Baptiste séminin revient vers vous
cher Jean en direct du Figaro love quel
est votre question à Valérie rabot oui
Valérie rabot hier sur Youtube Emmanuel
Macron a annoncé le lancement d'un grand
plan RER pour 10 villes en France il a
aussi vanté les mérites du train de nuit
est-ce que vous pensez que ce sera
suffisant pour désenclavé ce que
certains appellent la France
périphérique
mais écoutez je sais pas ce que
concrètement le président de la
République souhaite faire moi ce que
j'observe c'est que sur les
infrastructures de transport et bien les
investissements ont baissé depuis 7-8
ans dans notre pays donc il doit manquer
aller entre 5 et 6 milliards d'euros par
an par rapport si on prenait
l'équivalent en termes de points de PIB
auparavant j'observe que moi je suis
dans une région l'Occitanie qui est la
seule à ne pas avoir de ligne LGV alors
vous allez me dire LGV c'est pas les
transports du quotidien vous aurez
raison sauf que toutes nos lignes sont
aujourd'hui complètement engorgées donc
pour les désengorger ça permet de mettre
les grandes lignes sur des voies et puis
de mettre les TER sur d'autres et que
sur cette ligne LGV Bordeaux Toulouse et
bien l'état demande aux collectivités
d'en payer 40% ce qui est une première
et ce qui s'est jamais fait dans toutes
les autres lignes LGV donc moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est un plan de financement
global les petites lignes les intersités
les TER et que on est une réflexion
véritablement globale sur le transport
j'ai été au mois de juillet dernier en
Allemagne où ils ont mis un ticket de
train 9 euros 9 euros par mois qui a été
testé de train qui vous permet de
voyager partout sauf les ITS
là vous avez une baisse du trafic
automobile de 10 %. donc c'est à dire
que quand vous avez des trains qui
fonctionnent qui sont pas cher vous
prenez le train et vous n'hésitez pas
moi je vous citer un autre cas d'une
commune de matières conscription qui est
à Lexos et bien c'est un train qui
permet d'aller à Toulouse en 1h15 sauf
qu'ils enseignent en avoir 6 par jour
parfois il n'a pas toujours donc c'est
ça qu'il faut que le Président de la
République si on fait un vrai plan
ferroviaire là ça deviendra intéressant
avec un peut-être un pass comme si sera
en Allemagne
de prendre le train
en disant qu'en Allemagne le trafic
avait baissé 10% contre le billet était
pas cher et que c'était un pass qui a
servi à beaucoup de personnes la
présidente
la présidente socialiste d'ailleurs
co-autrice de l'attribut avec vous dans
le JDD Carole des gars a salué l'annonce
d'Emmanuel Macron plus enthousiaste que
vous on va le dire elle a été plus en
plus que moi c'est vrai voilà merci
beaucoup Jean-Baptiste merci beaucoup
Valérie rabot et René Paul Savary
c'était très encore une fois très très
bien cette tonalité de débat entre vous
donc on se félicite que ça a été sur LCP
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine et
Public Sénat bien sûr pour audition
publique à 19h30 merci à vous et bonne
semaine à tous
[Musique]